not really sir Ashley Madison okay
Ashley Madison why don't you explain
yeah it's a dating site with a huge
caveat it's for people who are already
in relationships but looking to pursue
that pervert or something on the side so
it's for cheaters basically and you are
married but you are enthusiastic about
having an affair it's an entrepreneur
and so when I saw that a huge percentage
of people going to traditional dating
sites weren't truly single that there
was maybe an alternative path for them
yeah I thought I would build something
and we built that she masks not about
power did you ever heard of Ashley
Madison before this morning I had not
you had not all right no last you in the
break I love this would you invest and
your answer is at a price at a price no
for you was it there's a market for
everything or was there a deep reason
you're saying ma'am I love to date this
girl let's make a real market for it you
know it's the outer prices I think
philosophy I was a sports attorney I
think there was infidelity in my
professional DNA in a sense and so when
I saw that data it was really compelling
to me it was you know we all know
Affairs happen I don't think we're that
naive and I think that we might be blown
away by how many people the day after
Valentine's they will come to a service
like ours but I think the opportunity
was there and I want to pursue it I
could have imagined it being in 35
countries with 25 million members but
that's what it's become I will Howard I
will tell you that I just learned this
this morning as well but the day after
Valentine's Day for a cheating website
is like Black Friday
it's like Ashley why why do you think
you know valve Ezeiza as a litmus test
of sorts right so if you have
expectations let me down well yeah if
you have expectations and it can be of
romance it can't be able whole things
just maybe even feeling better about
yourself if it once again just feels
hollow and it's not the first time it's
felt Hollow this is the second year it's
felt Hollow it's been going on for 10
years whatever ends up being you're
gonna do something different you can do
a lot of things that might be people
would say are healthier you could do you
know join a gym see our therapist but
you might also find a lover what's
healthier than sex right well yeah
there's romance in that too right
there's a form of romance right how do
you cash in on the fact that tomorrow
everybody's logging in do sell more ad
space how does it work no so Ashley
Madison sells no advertising yeah all of
our revenues are a hundred percent
subscription-based but in a
non-traditional way it's not that you
actually you know give us a monthly
subscription and then send as many
messages as you want we charge you per
message
it's kind of pay as you play and that
way people have to really think about
their communication strategy because
that's why women come to an affair they
want to be an object of desire again and
so we cash in because the market becomes
imbalanced for the old that day we have
more women than men that is the only day
of the year can I first ask we have
Howard if he's surprised by this from a
different era every year we are now just
using technology I didn't get I didn't
get the memo as a guy who uses
technology to do a number of things you
worry about the paper trail so it is
really great do I have to use all
additional email address we call it
digital lipstick it's not lipstick on
your collar get in your car anymore it's
the digital lipstick your phone or your
email account
does she know it is there a way to do it
with like anonymously is there a Bitcoin
version Madison well to us you know the
perfect affair is meeting someone and
not being discovered so everything we do
from the moment you sign up is all about
the discretionary part of it for example
when you finish on a traditional dating
site you're really just taking your
profile to circulation on Ashley Madison
we'll go back and recall every message
you ever sent every photo you ever
shared we make it like you're a ghost
that you never even existed all right
we're thinking it through
do you have meet and greets we do not
you know we keep it my role in this is
the introductory platform a place where
you can safely publish who you are what
why and how you're coming to an affair
what happens in the real world that's up
you know today I ask you one second have
you been subpoenaed and any divorces no
you know thankfully in America we've
woken up to a reality that people get
divorced for a host of reasons and
really infidelity is just a symptom it's
not that you know somewhere they go
we've never been they get divorced more
and we know this before I even read
these facts we know this to be true in
Park Slope in Tribeca wait we need to
ask Howard what he thinks Howard's an
Upper East Side guy where do you think
what neighborhood has the most
infidelity in the five boroughs Staten
Island that's a great answer and
probably true but look the kind of
infidelity that uses the internet to
make it happen you know that's happening
in Park Slope you know what's happening
in
Rebecca but you know we also that we do
incredibly well with affluent
communities we also do incredibly well
in it such as a recession-proof business
we did incredibly well in tough economic
times in Spain we do really well when
people need their partner the most
they've lost their job they've lost
their confidence they sometimes get them
the least and you believe Old Westbury
is on their I can't believe Brooklyn
Heights is on their communities with
again I'm the one here who's trying to
say just because someone hasn't fair
doesn't mean they're not good people
that notion has to go away right I don't
care if it's presidents famous
entertainers athletes or your best
friend it just means they're struggling
with monogamy doesn't mean there's some
kind of sociopath
so you're saying monogamy is a choice
it's you know it doesn't mean you're a
bad person
except it's a man-made construct it's
not really in our DNA and so we're
really poor at exercise I'm going to go
ahead and publicly disagree with you if
you're cheating on your wife
you're a bad thing the reason Ashley
Madison is this successful is because
women and their approach to infidelity
is what's dramatically changed in the
last decade
Josh marks you are one of the most
respected businesspeople
I know do you think it is now socially
acceptable doesn't make you a bad person
if you are a cheetah honey first of all
if you're watching I'm not involved
there is no price anymore there's no
price anymore well I think we're all
complex we all multifaceted and there
are lots of people who are good people
in many ways and and do bad things do
bad things and there are people who are
monogamous who are bad in other ways
yeah I would say okay maybe it doesn't
make you a bad person but it's
definitely the wrong thing to do if
you're having an affair with the with
someone else but we're not behind any
doors warn in front of your friends
we're not behind your go know what's add
to that you know what we hear all the
time from our members is I love and
cherish my children my economic
situation my home my extended family I
don't want to leave all that just to
find something different in the best I
think we should point so I just want to
frame I want you are one of there's four
of us sitting on this set you're the
only unmarried one
don't necessarily have a clear
complicated road amazing the reason is
because I take marriage very seriously
you'll never do it yes yes I want to
know what's your growth strategy clearly
you are making it happen there is a
market for it Fidel in fidelity it
exists how you building it for an
investor in Howard well it's amazing if
you were if you're in the single dating
space it's really hard to build a
universal product you know people date
differently in India your parents have
to be involved in China family name and
economics or so so the traditional
models that the US would build out
wouldn't necessarily work but in
fidelity it turns out it's pretty global
even in cultures were prohibited by law
people still do it it's that much of a
biological drive so we are now in 35
countries 15 languages and there's
really no marketplace that we can't see
us expanding into there in one language
the language of love no or lust you're
talking lust clean no that's talking
rectitude what is that rectitude
rectitude I'm uh I have to say someone
just messaged me and said look if you're
cheating on your wife you can't be
trusted and I think you know what agree
with that okay can't be trusted in
public office so I think that's that's a
historically bad notion